let's address this and first i want to
give us we got a story here breaking
down a little bit what we got usa today
reports truck convoy nearing nation's
capital pentagon okay's use of national
guard vaccination drive stalls as
omicron fades covet updates as many as
700 national guard are prepared to take
posts across the nation's capital amid
planned trucker protest convoys that
organizers say could paralyze the city
without entering it bob bolas a
pennsylvania truck driver says he's
leading the freedom convoy of trucks
from pennsylvania to washington on
wednesday but he told nbc 4 in
washington that he has backed off
immediate plans to gridlock the capital
we're not shutting the traffic down
today if we don't have a resolution from
the uh from the government to the rights
that they're taking from us i will
predict in the future it will get shut
down so you've got there's this
pennsylvania convoy coming from the
north you've got the people's convoy
coming from california i think freedom
convoy is also california right correct
and there's also one coming from
maryland and the guy he's running for
governor in maryland he's also there but
like there's some like iffyness because
like it's just one truck and his tires
got slashed so many things happen at one
time interesting so i think these
protests are incredibly effective nay
ian i believe they may be the most
effective we've seen in our lifetimes
because i've i've seen many and perhaps
you could argue the george floyd riots
got a lot done for black lives matter
yeah but those are riots not protests
and we know the establishment has been
defending and supporting these violent
extremists in terms of a protest you
look at what happened in ottawa
boy did that generate press it made the
issue of border vaccines the number one
story which is it's it's important the
squeaky wheel gets the grease which is
why non-violent civil disobedience works
when you go out and you stage a
disruptive protest you'll get a slap on
the wrist you'll get arrested and i
think you should because you're crossing
a line but it's a line we say okay okay
we get it you wanted people to hear you
all of a sudden the news says hey that
disruption it was because of this
so if you look at the ottawa protests
how many people were talking about
vaccine mandates on the border not a
whole lot the truckers get in their
trucks they drive to ottawa and all of a
sudden for three or four weeks one of
the one of the biggest stories
internationally was this trudeau was
forced to to i don't think he was
necessarily forced to i don't think they
need to use emergency powers but the
mask slips now we can see you got you've
got regular people saying this is
fascism this is martial law it has
exposed the despotism of these of this
establishment one grain of sand at a
time i'm not going to pretend like
there's a revolution overnight from
trucker honk and their horns but people
can see the double standard they can see
the the bs hierarchy we call it now not
hypocrisy that the left gets away with
this stuff and the right gets punished
for it and you can see the lengths
they're willing to go to maintain power
that's the main thing because like no
one would have ever expected that
trudeau would just invoke a terrorism
clause just like that
just to get a hold of how people are
supporting these truckers like just
think about that for a fact like
to think about the fact that this
the thing which they did in terms of
like freezing the bank accounts and even
to reach as far as the crypto stuff
like the fact that trudeau went that far
i think that just credits the truckers
that without them putting this
up front and center no one would have
guessed that the prime minister could go
as far as to getting a hold of your
personal bank account i think that they
would invoke terrorism stuff because of
the violence because of the noise and
and
roll ones all you want guys but noises
can be violent you can kill someone with
too much noise terrorism though that
that has terrorism by definition has
like a political motive to it
i think that they were trying to scare
people or this is the mentality of what
they're gonna say they're trying to
scare people to get their politics
accomplished
ian come on man
i know but this is my i'm wargaming the
scenario right now a fascist
dictatorship will use this argument and
say your honking is violent you are
aggressing on the people and we're going
to invoke whatever we need to stop and
that is exactly why it was an effective
protest because any sane rational person
is hearing that going what yeah
what are you talking about but when
you're there yeah i thought it was just
until i watched a video of a guy that
lives there and it's like okay it's not
just honking like it's it's non-stop all
day i mean it's gonna be you know not
comfortable but i agree with sonic's
take where i think what happened in
ottawa actually exposed the canadian
government because i think we've all you
know all of us were like hey they
wouldn't go that far then we saw the
freezing of the bank accounts then we
saw the videos of these police officers
rolling up to these truckers just
busting out their windows then we saw
the viral footage of that disabled woman
trampled by the horse so i think that
actually did was actually really
effective in exposing the canadian
government because we never knew that
they could be that authoritarian i mean
up to mine my concern is if you want to
expose the american government in its
fascist ways
okay but if you hold a piece of meat out
in front of a hungry wolf and it bites
your hand yeah you exposed it for being
the dumb idiot animal that it was but at
what was the cost of the exposition i
don't i don't need to sacrifice a bunch
of truckers to prove that what do you
mean the fascist dictatorship has taken
over our government 100 years ago what
do you mean by sacrifice i don't want to
see people go to solitary to try and
just to prove that biden's in the hand
of klaus schwab or some
you know
like the federal reserve it's so fascist
this whole system we're
we don't need to hurt ourselves to prove
this right now we need to fix it
fascistic i think is the better word you
know you know what i don't like about
people saying communism and fascism is
that they're they're they represent no
they represent 100 years ago when we had
this these rising ideologies in europe
they were specific now we've got a lot
of technology that has changed how it's
being implemented and
when you know trudeau and biden and they
use these authoritarian powers it's like
fashion fascism it's it's weird they saw
what there's a meme where they fold the
political compass authoritarian right
you know and left over it's like
whatever china is doing yeah it's like
yeah no exactly it's like a weird new
thing but i will respond to you ian
by saying
we don't want violence
violence doesn't work because the
establishment preys upon it when when
you look at january 6th it was
everything the democrats and
and the neocon never trumpers wanted
because now they could justify
everything and we've got a system of
laws that say oh you got violent we got
you now the truckers it was amazing they
were annoying they were annoying that
was it people were annoyed by them the
people a lot of people weren't annoyed
by it they were just like dancing in the
street they were having a good time
what happens though is the powerful
elites don't know how to deal with it
because you're not doing anything it's
like going outside of someone's house
and just protesting yelling it's like
you're allowed to do it well but the
noise violations you gotta be careful
like i do support
a silent protest which a bunch of trucks
just stopped in the roads
and you for
have to think about the protesters like
these truckers have been through so much
have been through all these crazy
mandates and now they're seeing that
anytime they cross you know into canada
they're
technically this like electronic qr code
you know for them enough is enough and i
don't think honking is the worst thing
in the world not just that like as
journalists we focus on narrative
imagery binaries like think about the
imagery of the state of the union going
on and god bless biden's speechwriters
because i don't know what he's going to
talk about at that time
but state of the union going on and at
the same time all these truckers outside
the capital just blocking everything
so that's like um optical and you're
going to hear this that's an optic
that's a binary in front of you right
there whatever like biden cooks up at
that speech i don't know what he will
but there are people who are just
literally saying stop this stuff we need
to go back to what it was can you can
you imagine if like for the state of the
union joe biden just comes out
100 honest and he's like in my first
year i my policies have driven massive
inflation high gas prices where we have
a new war performing in eastern europe
afghanistan was a massive they chose me
to be here in the first place we got a
fentanyl crisis killing americans unless
you're brain right there so like dude
but i would love him if he did that
i would i agree if he came out and
actually was just like totally honest
with everything i respect it yeah i'd be
like wow yeah like i think i think that
would actually in in in some respect
make him one of the best presidents
we've ever had for just coming out and
laying bare everything i might be
getting too old for this job too
i need you guys to know that i'm not who
i use sorry for me to talk
i'm there with you i want to go to bed
yeah why am i here
so i will respond i will respond to your
point though ian those who make peace uh
peaceful revolution impossible make
violent revolution inevitable kennedy
they do that and you factor that for me
the other day yeah
yeah and yeah i mean to be honest yeah
the gandhi protests yeah but even even
black lives matter like if they like for
example this is an example let's just
let's just say they brought a hundred
thousand people
to you know the the capital non-violent
protests peaceful demonstration they
actually would have got a lot more done
i mean fast forward to this year black
lives matter i mean to to be honest they
really haven't gotten much done the only
people that have really benefited are
the founders like patrice killers who
are now richer than ever god deals with
levi got deals with youtube got you know
buying mansions and malibu um but
everyone else hasn't got anything from
it i mean there's literally local groups
all over the country if you guys look it
up that are very angry with black lives
matter because they didn't do anything
to actually fund their movement we even
have um um some people that um some
mothers and fathers speaking out who's
had their you know son or daughter
killed by police who said hey black
lives matter came and all they did was
just griff like literally they got rich
and we didn't even see a dollar back
into the community so even black lives
matter with their violent protest even
though the media was on their side they
technically didn't get anything
accomplished yeah and you gotta
understand we're dealing with this like
overarching culture war black lives
matter had for a long time corporate
support institutionalized support the
vice president supporting while they're
burning down buildings and quite
literally killing people aaron danielson
killed in portland by an antifa guy you
had the antifa guy firebomb the ice
facility you had 30 plus dead in the in
the george floyd riots and they still
receive institutional support and then
along comes some truckers and they honk
their horns and everybody loses their
minds and so i'm like yo i can tolerate
honking and i think the fact
it really is to me just so perfect to
show regular people when they're like
uh yeah my business was destroyed last
uh you know not last year but the year
before from the george floyd writes why
are you complaining to me and using
emergency powers over some guy honking
his horn it's a slap in the face to the
average person whose lives were
destroyed that you're going to have
someone come out and they're going to be
like noises violence so we're going to
crush you and freeze your banks they do
that the mask comes off and you're going
to have a lot of regular people
although i will admit i don't know how
many people are uninitiated at this
point but there's gonna be a lot of
people questioning
what what's going on correct like in a
bubble
like in the news bubble in the politics
bubble it may seem like pretty mundane
to us that people oh i hate the mandate
oh i hate the vaccine i hate masks but
if you think about it a normal people
saying like throw on the word normie
like who doesn't care about all this and
he just comes across like the dmv and
all these truckers are clogging up and
he starts asking the question hey what's
up what's going on why are these people
here and that kind of like
sparks the discourse within that
community and then they realize that oh
hey maybe the shelves are empty why are
the shelves empty because the truckers
are not bringing stuff across why the
trucker's not doing that because they
hate the mandates hey what's up with the
mandates but let's let's
make one more point for you again
when everybody goes out and smashes and
destroys things for the black for the
george ford riots
people on the right people who are not
even on the right who had their
businesses destroyed they're furious and
all of a sudden now they are gifted an
emotional release that has no long-term
damage correct they honk their horn and
they feel better they get to express
themselves and it kind of it can help
things depressurize because if you tell
these people they're not even allowed to
be noisy while the other other rioters
destroyed everything then you're going
to make violent revolution inevitable
when people lose their minds i i i could
see how what you're you guys are saying
like maybe that getting the wolf to snap
at your hand and and grab at the food is
important to show people like hey it's
not a puppy dog it's a wolf and wake
people up that way like the the 1970 may
4th kent state shooting vietnam protest
a bunch of students were out there and
then they're throwing rocks at the
national guard national guard opened
fire and killed four people um and that
shocked the country into awareness
basically brought about the end of
vietnam war more or less you know the
song that was written about it was
powerful too ohio uh by crosby stills
nation young
so maybe but i don't want to see a bunch
of people's lives get destroyed by some
stupid patriot act
you're right you're right and i think
it's their choice to make
and i also always want to say man you
know i mentioned other people get that
emotional release from it but i gotta
admit me having watched years a decade
of rioting
and the right never comes out in
protests and then finally when they do
for issues of freedom they get demonized
it feels good for me when i when i watch
truckers is going honk honk when i'm
tweeting the word honk in all caps the
the people are saying the cure for clown
world is honking well it's just like
it it feels good to be able to have
something it feels good no we don't want
to get violent i don't i think violence
is bad i don't want to see people get
hurt but man is it frustrating to see
the extremists on the left do all of
this stuff and get away with it and have
the media lie and cover up for them and
then you know what gets that you know
what happens i watch some truckers piss
off piss all of these people off by
honking no long-term damage to these
people no one's getting hurt they're
just getting frustrated and angry and it
feels good at the very least like thank
you we we we've expressed our outrage to
you that frustration we've had it allows
people to laugh about it thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 pm
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you